this just in the FBI says it will not
rest until every member of the different
strokes cast is behind bars
I was a long one you went like 20
seconds on me good now in 1975 he had us
laughing when he said I'm Chevy Chase
and you're not
tonight he's still Chevie chase and his
co-presenter is not I must say please
welcome two very funny men and my
friends Martin Short and Chevy Chase
hey hey hey you the category we are
presenting is live action short film
it means films feature that live actors
and under 30 minutes in length
hi I was under the impression that a
short film was a film made by Martin
Short oh no no no I film a by Martin
Short is called a classic no no uh these
are short films in terms of overall
length of film you know short meaning
not long I see yeah and then how would
you define live-action oh well that
would be a film featuring something
happening on the screen that moves like
you know a fight or a chase you see
oh well chase film is a film that I
appear in but I qualify for this award
ha ha ha what is your IQ anyway Chevy
not by yourself no way but I suppose if
we made a film together it could be
called a short chase film and we could
both qualify for an Oscar you see and if
we got Oscar de la Renta to appear in it
you see me then it would be a short
chase Oscar film and there would be some
reason for us showing up at these awards
every year wouldn't there Marty ha ha I
love when you're in a role Chevy it's
it's just it's it's so sad really
but that's oh well then let's just
continue on and announced the nominees
for live-action short films this year
and they are Bronx cheers raymandy
Phyllida and matthew gross
dear Rosie Peter Kathy Jo and Barnaby
Thompson
the lunch date Adam Davidson
sends any knock or what have we done
bernard japa and anthony be nicholas
volvo one PM hillary rips and jonathan
Heba and this year the award for live
action short film goes to no please
and the Oscar goes to the lunch date
Adam Davidson
look this is really a great thrill thank
you
it's also very scary too because it
really is just a ten-minute student film
I did for a class I'd like to thank all
those people who volunteered to help the
student film particularly my actors
Scottie block kliebert Ford Paul Sarnoff
Bernard Johnson also my co-producer
Garth Stein somewhere up there
let's see angle Decca Thomas cabinets
and Stuart Emanuel Claudia more my
family my school Columbia University
that's it thank you
ladies and gentlemen on his 50th
anniversary what what do you want to
pick out money best animated short film
our milk red apples okay nominees for
best animated short film our this is
ridiculous
create your comforts Nick art a grand
day out Nick art grasshopper
Bruno but settled and the winner is
creature comforts Nick Park
I'd like to thank Aardman Animations in
Bristol England
that's Peter Lord in David's Broxton and
all the team in Bristol and also channel
4 TV and thanks to Spike and Mike for
bringing me here
we want to thank Woody Woodpecker for
filling it at the last minute for Mickey
Mouse Mickey wanted to be here tonight
but he's having dinner with his new
partner Peggy Lee woof fastball outside
corner you know once upon a Hollywood
there was an enormous lead talented
actor who had an Oscar and he had an
enormous lead talented son and he won an
Oscar and he had an enormous lead
talented daughter and she won an Oscar
may do so again tonight ladies and
gentlemen happily ever after here is
Angelica Houston